bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france d'abord la
situation en afrique du sud
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
aujourd'hui sur l'évolution du variant
sud africain on a dépassé le bad
maintenant il y n'y a que 100 et entre
150 mots par jour
le pic était le 21 janvier et il n'y a
que deux ou trois mille nouvelles cas
par jour donc aller on a dépassé le pic
est maintenant attendre le vaccin de
johnson & johnson qui est très efficace
contre le nouvel varions en afrique du
sud
les derniers étude nous a montré qu' il
y à 85% efficacité contre le maladie qui
atteint sévèrement les gens ah et puis
on va avoir les doses dans la semaine
prochaine justement l'afrique du sud qui
s'est dite prête hier à revendre ou
échanger un million de doses du vaccin
astrazeneca qu'elle a écarté au profit
de johnson & johnson comment est ce que
vous avez accueilli cette nouvelle
je crois que les bonnes nouvelles pour
nous parce que le vaccin dachau
syndicats n'y avait que 22 % efficacité
à contes russes ceux qui ont légèrement
au monde réaffecte ballack obi 19 donc
on ne sait pas que ce qui se bat et on
le donne avec ceux qui ont l'écomobilité
et risque d'être gravement malade donc
le nouveau de le battre à johnson &
johnson est beaucoup plus je croise
efficace que la jordanie cas justement
sur cette étude de l'université de
witwatersrand à johannesburg
j'ai pas très bien prononcer le nom
d'université désolé qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire sur cette étude ont
donc qui affirme que astrazeneca oxford
a été efficace à seulement 22% contre
les formes modérées du variant locale en
2000 gens qui ont été étudiées et le
moins en gt 31 ans donc on ne sait pas
ce qui s'est passé avec ceux qui sont
plus agiles
quand on pas trop en fait que les gens
qui sont plus âgées comme beaucoup plus
atteinte avec l'éco mobilité les
tensions intérieures
ceux qui sont des bases obèses aussi
donc les critiques et un peu ce que le
nombre était assez peu tandis que le le
johnson johnson l'étude
là bas il y avait 44 mille gens qui
étaient inclus parmi 3 p aux états unis
brésil et l'afrique du sud et ceux de la
fille qu'il y avait 6 mai 10 mille plus
que si mes jambes a pris de ce qui était
étudié tous les gens en afrique du sud
ils ont atteint par le cos vie qu'ils ne
le baril en sud africain alors il est
aussi le ms a recommandé le vaccin
astrazeneca pour les plus de 65 ans
qu'est ce que vous vous pensé justement
de ces recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé ce que cela peut
influencer justement la position de
pretoria aujourd'hui vis-à-vis du vaccin
britannique
difficile à dire parce que si on accepte
de donner les gens je dois donc il va
avoir un peu protection dans les actes
indélicats mais pas n 2 qui doit et qui
doit être donné deux fois et puis il
faut ajouter on va ajouter le vin de
john john temps entre temps si on
utilisait le mielvaque tas qui sont
arrivés on va le donner le vaccin john
challenger supplémentaire au spi alors
justement où on est là la stratégie de
vaccination en afrique du sud en sachant
que astrazeneca est écarté et l'option
johnson & johnson c'est celle qui
prévaut pour l'instant où on est la
stratégie combien de doses du vaccin
johnson & johnson vous attendez je crois
on attendait 9 millions et puis au moins
80 80 milles qui va être qui va arriver
dans la semaine prochaine bon on a
commandé 9 millions pour commun des
blues ça veut dire quoi concernant la
campagne de vaccination l'afrique du sud
actuellement où elle où en est l on va
commencer avec les ouvriers
les médecins ceux qui travaillent dans
les hôpitaux c'est les gens qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux qui vont
être vaccinés en premier ligne
et puis j'imagine les âges et les gens
avec le conte mobilité mais pour le
moment c'est le déroulement dans les
hôpitaux il faut les ouvrir et dans les
hôpitaux alors vous savez qu'en europe
on privilégie astrazeneca en tout cas en
france la campagne de vaccination avec
le vaccin britannique a commencé pour
les plus de 65 ans les personnels
soignants
on craint aussi à l'évolution des
variants sur en europe
est-ce que vous il faut craindre le
variant sud-africain vous pensé puisque
d'autres bon je ne sais pas on peut
craindre le vaillant qui va arriver au
niveau aussi mais on ne peut pas
utiliser un vaccin qui n'y a que 22 son
efficacité mais on va essayer d'abord
avec le batteur johnson johnson et
l'aigle et les entreprises va fournit
aussi les vaccins contre les aryens un
tel compte ils sont taries c'est le
principe cité devient plus facile à
travailler avec les variants on y arrive
et pour fournit des nouveaux vaccins et
on doit craindre je précise ma question
doit craindre l'arrivée du vaccin du
variant sud africain ou harcelé en
europe
oui en europe oui oui j'imagine que le
varia frédéric 9 arrigoni haut niveau
c'est difficile a empêché merci beaucoup
à vous alan peter rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste merci pour cette
intervention en direct de johannesburg